alrighty today my review of squid game
which is the biggest show on netflix and
maybe in netflix history we'll get to
all of the details in just one moment
first this video is sponsored by helix
sleep
[Music]
first off this is gonna be filled with
spoilers so if you haven't actually seen
the squid game and you want to watch
this very disturbing show and you don't
want to know what's about to happen then
you really shouldn't watch this review
until after you've actually watched the
show unless you're producer eliot in
which case you're screwed because you
actually have to film this and
well tough so the basic premise of squid
game is essentially hunger games crossed
with parasite that's the elevator pitch
it's basically a guy who is living in
poverty he is divorced he has a bad
relationship with his ex-wife he's kind
of a derelict he's a gambler and he's
fallen into tremendous amounts of debt
with a gang with some sort of mob and
he eventually is approached by a man in
a subway station who decides to play a
game with him and the stakes of the game
are that if he loses then the man gets
to slap him in the face really really
hard and if he wins then the guy gives
him money so this goes on for a few
rounds keeps losing and losing and
losing finally he wins some money and
the guy hands him a card and says if you
want to play more games like this then
let me know he of course decides that
he's going to call the number he ends up
being kidnapped sort of and taken to a
place where they play these children's
games and they're going to be six rounds
of the children's games and if you make
it through all six rounds then you win
this massive pot of money what they
don't tell you is that if you lose the
games then you die so the very first
episode you have them play red light
green light and everybody who moves
during the red light phase of the game
is immediately shot by snipers to death
you kind of see this coming frankly like
if you knew anything about the show or
if you had any idea of where this was
going this was not a giant surprise the
first episode is not particularly gory
but it is kind of disturbing in that
everybody is being killed off but you
know very much like battle royale the
the japanese precursor to hunger games
or hunger games itself as the show goes
on the games become more and more scary
you have a couple of other characters
who are introduced you have a young
woman who's escaped from north korea
who's essentially attempting to win the
money so that she can give the money to
a trafficker to get her mom out of north
korea and also so that she can afford to
buy a house with her younger brother you
have a mob member who is attempting to
pay off his bad old debts a crazy woman
whose backstory you don't actually
really get you have a friend of the main
character who made something of himself
and now has mysteriously ended up in
this game and the reason is because he
attempted embezzlement and he used money
he didn't own in order to try and buy
futures and the futures went south and
so he ends up buying millions and
millions of won and there's this old man
who's tagging along because he has brain
cancer and he figures i may as well win
some money for my family before i die
and they go through various permutations
meanwhile there's sort of a side story
where a cop infiltrates and he's trying
to figure out who's at the head of this
organization that's attempting to create
these games and and torture these people
it's kind of an interesting setup in one
episode the people are actually allowed
to be let go because the rules of the
game are once you sign up you have to
play if you don't play you get shot but
if a majority of the players at any
given time decide they no longer want to
play the game then the entire game is
disbanded and the money that was
collected for the game is distributed to
the families of the people who died so
in an early episode that's one of the
things that happens everybody sort of
goes back to their regular life and then
of course they end up coming back to the
game because they have no options in the
outside world and this really brings us
to the central sort of parasite aspect
of squid game it is a dystopian thriller
and so the politics are very communistic
in nature the politics for this very
large budget show which is being shown
on netflix which is a high market cap
tech company are extraordinarily far to
the left the basic idea is that
capitalism provides so little
opportunity that you would rather play a
game where you might get shot just to
make money than attempt to live out your
life in the regular world and you see
some of the other characters who are in
the regular world right so the main
character who again is sort of a
derelict and a gambler his mom is trying
to live a normal life but she's got
diabetes and she doesn't have enough
money to pay for her surgical care so
she might lose her feet for example you
have the the mother of the guy who is
corrupt and embezzling and she runs like
a very small stand but is obviously
living in some form of poverty you have
the north korean escapee who is
basically
almost homeless and who is forced to
steal money and there's a scene where
the north korean escapee is asked by
another character you escaped from north
korea was it worth it and the answer
seems to be not really which is kind of
a strange take because north korea is a
giant gulag it's a giant prison camp so
no matter what you think of south korea
it is not comparable in any way shape or
form to the lifestyle in north korea
where people are on average several
inches shorter than people in south
korea because of malnutrition also if
you make a show criticizing the regime
in south korea it goes viral and ends up
on netflix if you create a show
criticizing the regime in north korea
they strap you to the front of an
anti-aircraft gun and then open fire
so that seems to be a slight difference
but the basic idea here is the same as
the basic idea in parasite which is that
if you are poor in south korea there is
no way up the ladder because capitalism
is evil and there are a bunch of kind of
notes that are that are put into the
show that underscore this very silly
theme one of those notes is that when
you get to the ending episodes and you
find out who are the vips who bet on who
is going to win and who's going to lose
the game they're all american like
they're all these big american fat cats
so it's really the evil americans
they're capitalist excesses these
decadent americans who are behind this
whole thing there's not a good american
in the entire show they're just a bunch
of americans who are wearing these
glittery masks a la hunger games and
this is supposed to characterize the
idea that really south korean economics
is run at the behest of these evil
white corporate pay masters the biggest
spoiler of course is that the person
who's heading up the squid game is the
old man right so the old man is playing
and it turns out that he's playing out
of fun he's not actually playing because
he is worried about dying he does have
brain cancer that part's true but he's
the head of a major corporation he's a
very wealthy industrialist and his
entire shtick is that all of this is
justified squid game is justified
because it is in fact more fair than the
actual capitalist economy that is in
place in south korea okay this is a very
silly view of capitalism capitalism is
literally predicated on the notion that
you do not get something unless you give
somebody something to somebody else as
hayek was fond of suggesting the basic
premise of capitalism is that you are
forced to do something you wouldn't have
normally done for somebody else because
you need something from them trade
ennobles trade is good but for people
who don't understand capitalism and come
from sort of a marxist leaning benz
capitalism is a zero-sum game somebody
wins and somebody loses somebody wins
the big pot of cash and somebody dies of
course the metaphor inside the squid
game is supposed to be that if only if
only the population sees the means of
production through majority votes then
all of this would end and we would usher
in a new and better world right all it
takes is a majority vote to stop this
terrible system where some people are
being murdered for the benefit of other
people okay but that assumes that
economics is a zero-sum game
right which it is not it assumes that
capitalism is a zero-sum game
which it is not we'll get some more on
this in just one second first i need my
helix sleep mattress i really really do
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress you
know will be perfect for the way that
you sleep everybody's unique and helix
knows that so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they've got soft they've got firm
they've got medium mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot mattress is great for spinal
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains even a helix plus mattress for
plus size sleepers as well i took that
helix sleep quiz i was matched with a
special mattress actually it has a
couple of different sides because my
wife and i got an all-in-one mattress
and she has different sleep settings
than i do you can do exactly the same so
if you are looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress
that you're matched to and then it shows
up directly at your door shipped for
free you don't even need to go to a
mattress store at all helix is awesome
you don't need to take my word for it
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq and
wired magazine and they've been
recommended by multiple leading
chiropractors and doctors of sleep
medicine as a go-to solution for
improvement in sleep quality so head on
over to helix sleep dot com slash ben
take that two minute sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that'll give you the best sleep of your
life you've got a 10 year warranty you
can try it out for a hundred nights risk
free so even if you don't love it you
can send it back but you will you're
gonna love it helix is offering up to
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at helix
sleep.com ben again that's
helixsleep.com for that special deal
the sort of capitalist critique rings
pretty hollow
and doesn't have a lot of support other
than sort of the polemical notion that
anybody who's involved in the capitalist
system
is somehow corrupt and evil you
literally see no business people other
than people who are exploitative or
embezzling okay i didn't like parasite
for this very reason because it seemed
like sort of a brainless critique of
capitalism my critique of parasite is
that the poor people in parasite are
supposed to be sympathetic but they
literally do nothing right and the rich
people in parasite are supposed to be
bad and therefore worthy of punishment
and they literally don't do anything
that is immoral in the course of the
movie like at all and yet you're just
supposed to assume that the rich people
are bad and the poor people are somehow
good the same thing sort of holds true
in this show in this show all of the
poor people are perceived as sort of
innately more noble than the people who
are rich even though the reality is that
the poor people in the show aside from
the north korean refuge the main
character is a derelict gambler he's a
bad guy
okay and he's gradually ennobled by his
participation in the game is sort of the
idea but all of the characters who are
seen to participate in the capitalist
system are of course very very bad and
so that's the political take on the show
and it seems like that is the message
that is now being exported by the south
korean film industry
as far as the actual show itself like
whether it's entertaining or not yeah i
mean it's entertaining it's definitely
very watchable it extremely gory there's
a very bizarre side plot about selling
of bodily organs that gets really
graphic and kind of gross i will say i
thought the twists were predictable
maybe it's because i've watched too many
movies and maybe it's because i've
written stuff myself but it's pretty
obvious from the beginning that whoever
is going to be leading up the squid game
has to be an integral character
otherwise it has no meaning when you
reveal who's leading up the squid game
so that means that it can't be any of
the young people who get killed the only
person it could be theoretically is the
old man really so i kind of called that
one maybe three episodes in advance and
also the other big mystery of the show
is that you have a cop who's trying to
search for his brother who's supposedly
been taken into the system and it turns
out that he is a part of the system that
again was not super unpredictable but
overall if he had to rate squid game in
terms of watchability and and sort of
addictiveness pretty good show i'd give
it maybe a seven out of ten in terms of
politics i give it like a one out of ten
because again the politics of it are so
baseline hollywood silly they really
make no level of actual sense presumably
they're setting up for a second season
of squid game as well because the season
ends on a cliffhanger with the main
character basically deciding that he is
going to go take down the squid game as
opposed to leaving the country and
heading off to america so i'm sure that
that will be the second season he will
probably have to infiltrate or you'll
have to figure out some way to enter
into the system itself which you know
i'll start to watch it for sure but is
it worthy of the sort of high praise
that it's been receiving in some
quarters probably not is it watchable
for sure
the good
compelling
well acted
well produced
interesting it's a beautiful looking
show the sets that they built for the
various games are really intricate they
look really good they're sort of oddly
creepy because the sets that they built
for the children's games it's supposed
to be almost as though they're in this
kind of giant doll house the feel of the
show is is really good it's well filmed
it's well directed the most compelling
episode is episode six because it really
forces the characters to take stock of
the fact that they essentially have to
kill other people in order to get ahead
but again it's a metaphor for capitalism
it's very silly but it's very
emotionally affecting and it does put
the characters in a really difficult
emotional bind so it's well written and
it's well acted that is probably the
best episode of the show the bad
politically asinine politically it makes
no sense at all somewhat predictable in
terms of the twists and turns very very
bloody like super bloody so that first
episode is not an indicator of what the
bloodiness level will be in future
episodes that first episode just has
people getting shot
like in the head and it's fairly graphic
that is not even close to how graphic
the show ends up getting
they use some some old film and tv
tropes so bad guys listen to classical
music this is just a reality of the
world as we all know is that all bad
people listen to classical music cause
that means that they're woken up to the
blue danube walls by strauss uh and it
means that the bad guys are listening to
you know classic old jazz you like jazz
so those are the good and the bad
alrighty that is my review of squid game
if there are other shows that you'd like
me to review other movies you'd like me
to review leave a note in the comments
section below and leave us a like as
well